mais ces dames bien bonsoir je m'appelle
mbaïré lisette et je pense que mon
prénom est mon nom sont un bon reflet du
creuset d'où je viens
bairi prénom sarah du tchad
je suis complètement imprégné du piment
de la culture africaine
lisette guadeloupe un cabas les griots
le condo de moon je suis complètement
imprégné du piment de la culture
guadeloupéenne
tout ceci assaisonnez de culture basque
de piment d'espelette des cultures des
cultures attentive aux autres plus
réverse à liste pour paraphraser nous
penseurs caribéen la gestion de crise et
la gestion des effets papier alors
laissez-moi vous raconter une histoire
qui m'est arrivé il ya quelques années
au burkina faso j'anime et bénévolement
un programme de développement local et
notamment de refondation d'agriculture
en introduisant la culture attelée en
lieu et place de la daba 7 ou africaine
qui que quoi que respectueuse de
l'environnement peine avec la
désertification croissante à nourrir une
famille nous dotons des paysans de bleu
de charger tout se passe bien
la récolte s'annonce excellente et tout
d'un coup patatras
ne voilà-t-il pas qu'un rêve est
d'humeur vagabonde décide de vérifier
l'adage l'herbe est plus verte dans le
pré du voisin
il y va
ils broutent de tendre pousse le
propriétaire du champ survient prend un
coup de sang et là bas il faut dire ceci
s'inscrit dans une rivalité ethnique
sous jacente sans la médiation d'une
parenté à plaisanterie
les amis du propriétaire du boeuf s'en
émeuvent se rassemblent et décide
d'aller bastonner le propriétaire du
champ celui-ci rameute les siens et
s'ensuit une échauffourée avec quelques
blessures légères dues à des armes
blanches
les gendarmes interviennent et se
retrouve bastonné par les deux parties
vous comprenez que la maréchaussée
n'apprécie pas du tout et elle décide
embastillé tout ce beau monde qui
s'empresse de s'égayer dans la brousse
commence une partie de cache cache à 3
chacun voulant en découdre avec les deux
parties et ceci peut très vite se
transformer en un drame mortel
heureusement dans notre groupe liens
anciens au sens initiée du terme
respectées par toutes les parties
tant par les autorités que par les
villageois il intervient et il arrive à
faire admettre aux gendarmes
d'abandonner les poursuites et de
n'infliger que des amendes aux fautifs
ils arrivent à faire admettre aux
villageois
le remboursement du boeuf pour l'un le
remboursement de la production perdue
pour l'autre finalement tout est bien
qui finit au mieux mais pour moi le
camouflet mon métier c'est la gestion
crise c'est anticiper c'est organiser la
résilience et le b à ba de la gestion de
crise c'est comme le principe dynastique
je le vois aller ainsi qui traîne voilà
la crise les tirs au métier c'est de
faire en sorte qu'ils ne cassent pas ils
reviennent à son état initial avec le
moins de dommages structurels possible
pour ce faire j'analyse j'essaie de
comprendre
j'utilise des grilles complexe pas
vraiment compliqué complexe
si je prends l'exemple d'une crise
environnementale
un cyclone est un risque de type
environnementale il va impacter lax
humain dès lors qu'il ya des victimes
il va impacter l'or l'or lax
organisationnel dès lors qu'il ya une
défection de compétences critiques et
vous voyez bien que si cette défection
compétences critiques
ce sont les médecins urgentistes cela va
venir aggravé l'impact team puisque on
aura plus personne pour soigner les
victimes
ça va impacter l'environnement et en
impactant l'environnement peut-être que
ça va détruire l'hôpital ce qui une fois
de plus va accentuer aggravé l'impact
humain puisqu'il n'y aura pas de lieu
pour les secourir donc le coeur du
métier c'est se pose la question de d
impact systémique et de pose et ceci en
termes de d'espacé de temps est-ce que
c'est la couvre un quartier est ce que
là cela couvre une île est-ce que cela
couvre une aire géographique et au delà
et à partir de là que peuvent que
pouvons nous mettre en place comme
mesures de réduction du risque et comme
mesure direction l'impact
je vous disais camoufler parce que les
éléments d'analysé je les avais la
divagation des animaux est un problème
récurrent connu et générateur de
conflits
et même si nous avons nous avions
demandé à tous de les maintenir en
enclos j'aurais pu j'aurais dû me poser
la question si l'un des deux s'échappe
quid j'étais suffisamment informés de la
complexité de la situation et nico
politique pour me poser des questions
regard de conflits de voisinage et
mettre en place des mécanismes de
médiation de recours en situation de
conflit larvé ou de koffi a viré eh bien
non j'ai allègrement tout oublié j'ai
allègrement oublier ce qui fait mon
coeur de métier analysé anticipé mettre
en place des mesures de réduction
alors certes je n'étais pas dans mes
menus de travail on l'a dit tout à
l'heure j'ai déployé
effectivement la gestion de crise des
plans de continuité d'activité sur tous
les continents
c'était pas une excuse alors en quoi
cela nous interpelle
en quoi cela vous interpelle si je vous
demande à vous qui êtes ici
confortablement installés détendu votre
téléphone vibre et votre interlocuteur
vous informe que votre maison a
intégralement brûlé
pas de victimes pas de dommages
corporels
que faites vous si vous en aviez
l'opportunité
qu'aimeriez vous récupérez alors la
première question que faites vous
d'aucuns me répondre je saute dans la
voiture et je vais voir ce qu'il en est
mauvaise idée
mauvaise pioche vous allez rouler vite
car vous êtes pressés d'arriver
vous allez conduire en mode réflexe
c'est à dire sans vraiment hâte en
porter attention à la route car vous
êtes déjà en train de projeter
mentalement ce que vous allez faire
certains même
van téléphoner en conduisant vous voyez
bien que vous augmenter de façon
significative la probabilité que vous
ayez un accident alors posez vous la
question qu'est ce que vous pourriez
faire avant de partir parce que 5 ou 10
minutes de plus ça ne changez votre
maison et votre famille elle est sain et
sauf
par contre prendre la peine d'appeler
vos proches
organisez votre hébergement organisé
l'école de vos enfants pour organiser le
quotidien de la vie qui vient appelez
votre assurance pour qu'elle vous
accompagne dans les formalités appelé la
mairie pour qu'elle vous accompagne dans
les démarches
appelez votre travail pour reporter ou
pour vous faire suppléeront telle ou
telle action urgente
là vous gagnez du temps là vous gagner
en efficacité
qu'aimeriez-vous récupérer certains me
disent où je sens qu'il va y avoir de
telles formalités administratives à
remplir que ce que je veux récupérer ce
sont mes papiers contrats d'assurance
actes de propriété que sèche
d'autres me disent dont moi va j'ai pris
tellement d'années pour dénicher cet
objet de valeur c'est celui là que je
voudrais les sentimentaux mais 10,1 en
masse et des photos les photos elles
datent de l'époque où il n'y a pas de
vidéo qu'il n'y avait pas de numérique
ce sont les photos de mes parents de mes
grands parents de ma fratrie de mots
phylum si je vais perdre et ce serait un
drame intime un drame personnel
alors je leur dis certes certes il ya
des choses que vous ne pourrez pas
récupéré et les papiers
des photos cela ce scan cela se
sauvegarde dans le cloud
cela se sauvegarde chez vos proches
alors bien sûr bien sûr vous n'aurez
plus la magie proustienne du support
mais vous aurez conserver une certaine
image de votre passé et ça que vous
soyez confronté à votre logique et
détruit ou simplement que vous devriez
évacuer que le dirigeant soit confronté
à la destruction son entreprise qu'un
élu lé soit confronté à l'instruction de
son quartier que des élus soient corée
soit confrontée comme haïti à des crises
beaucoup plus simple et bien il faut se
poser la question
avant quoi sauvegarder
comment s'organiser quel processus nous
devrions déclenché donc se préparer se
préparer c'est aussi sentir c'est sentir
quels sont les risques mais pas
simplement les risques connus que l'on
va qualifier au travers de méthodes
dites historiques ou méthodes du
portefeuille c'est à dire ce qui est
déjà arrivé dans votre secteur
d'activité ou dans votre environnement
ou dans des secteurs d'activités voisins
ou dans des environnements voisins c'est
se poser les questions de il faut
creuser faut creuser plus je vais vous
donner un autre exemple 2009
je prépare pour un de mes clients une
simulation de gestion de crise et genre
propose comme thématique crise politique
simultanée en tunisie et en côte
d'ivoire où dix scouts mailleraye tu
exagères tu vas quand même nous proposer
quelque chose de plus réaliste tu vois
bien que ce n'est pas possible
d'autres d'autres s'offusquent
comment une telle hypothèse en tunisie
on est encore sous la présidence de ben
ali mais il gouverne son pays d'une main
de fer ce n'est pas possible
j'assiste ils acceptent de jouer le jeu
nous faisons la simulation de crise et
elle met en évidence quelques failles
dans le dispositif de maîtrise de crise
qui était en place fin 2010
depuis début 2011 crise politique en
côte d'ivoire début du printemps arabe
en tunisie
finalement la répétition de 2009 aura
été utile on peut en tirer deux leçons
sur certaines caractéristiques
comportementales en situation de crise
la première c'est le déni le refus du
réel c'est cette fameuse phrase ce n'est
pas possible
cela n'est jamais arrivé cela ne peut
pas nous arriver
concentrons nous sur les risques connus
immédiat alors je dis oui certes certes
traitons les risques connus traitant les
risques immédiats mais dès que vous
entendez dès que vous entendez ce n'est
pas possible
ayez la puce à l'oreille car cela veut
dire que vous n'êtes pas préparé
tactiquement que vous n'êtes pas préparé
organisé organisationnellement vous
n'êtes pas prêt mentalement pour
affronter une crise ce type
le deuxième c'est la tendance naturelle
de l'humain à privilégier les hypothèses
optimistes
vous savez comme moi que l'on tue le
messager porteur de mauvaises nouvelles
et donc chacun inconsciemment ce four se
voudra porteur de bonnes nouvelles
surtout en face de l'autorité alors même
que ce rôle est un rôle essentiel c'est
le rôle du fou du roi
c'est celui qui à la fois candide et
cassandre est officiellement en charge
de montrer de mettre en évidence les
informations qui dérange de soumettre
les scénarios qui heurte alors la
méthode dialectique
méthode du ce n'est pas possible vous
entendez ce n'est pas possible
creuser creuser creuser creuser la
méthode métaphorique c il s'est passé
une crise grave dans un secteur dans un
environnement qui n'a rien à voir avec
vous nous sommes en guadeloupe
catastrophe au pôle nord je n'ai pas
tout à fait le même environnement
la métaphorique mais tom et afrique se
dire est ce que je peut transposer ce
qui est arrivé est est ce que je peux en
tirer certaines leçons identifier les
risques se prépare et mettre en place
des mesures de réduction du risque de
réduction d'impact s'entraîner ceci à
vocation sera le faire tout ceci en fait
a pour seule vocation de dégager du
temps de réflexion pour l'imprévu
parce que l'une des définitions de la
crise c'est l'irruption de l'imprévu
dans le prévu une des définitions de
l'effet papillon
c'est qu'une infime modification du
prévu peut générer un immense a prévu la
question comment prévoir l'imprévisible
comment anticiper ce dont on n'a aucune
idée de ce qui pourrait survenir
la première c'est me mettre en condition
de pouvoir y réfléchir d'avoir le temps
de le traiter
c'est pour ça que avancé préparer la
deuxième elle est intéressante dans le
contexte de tedx c'est que vous souvenez
l'ancien celui qui est venu apporter son
concours pour résoudre le problème est
bien l'idéal est là c'est de tisser un
réseau d' expertise de tisser
un réseau de solidarité qui pourra
apporter son concours pour vous aider à
gérer à traiter et peut-être à maîtriser
la prévu donc on ne peut pas prévoir
l'imprévisible
mais on peut se préparer à le traiter et
ceci c'est vrai pour les grandes
institutions c'est vrai pour les grandes
entreprises internationales mais c'est
vrai aussi
et c'est d'autant plus vrai pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises qui sont
en situation d'un cri sont d'autant plus
fragiles qu'elles n'ont pas l'assise
financière
elles n'ont pas l'assiette commercial
leur permettant de réduire l'impact de
la crise c'est valide aussi nous l'avons
vu avec l' incendie pour vous pour votre
famille pour vous et vos proches et si
je vais qu'on le voulait conclure je
n'arrive pas à conclure si je voulais
conclure je vous dirais nous sommes dans
un monde de crises crise éthique crise
culturelle crise intellectuelle crise
sociale crise politique crise
environnementale
notre enjeu
notre mode est en jeu c'est la volonté
que nous aurons à anticiper à nous
entraîner à nous organiser a trait à
dresser à tisser cette trame de
solidarité qui nous permettra de réduire
autant que faire se peut parce que bien
sûr nous ne pourrons pas tout faire qui
lui permettra de réduire autant que
faire se peut l'impact d'une crise sur
nos vies personnelles sur nos emplois
sur notre activité sur notre
environnement sur notre société
merci